geht oder geht jetzt gehts eine güte was ein krampf wieder
was ein akt trifft das hier ein richtig gut
sogar mit qualitätsoptionär ich habe extra neu gestartet
alter ist der delay niedrig ja das dürfte ein paar sekunden sein
warte mal gucken wir mal guck mal haben wir die uhr auf
55 56 57 jetzt sind 2 sekunden bei mir jetzt gerade
ja die uhr zwischen meinen beiden rechnern geht falsch sehe ich gerade hier 10 11 3 4 sekunden
3 4 sekunden das relativ niedrig so einen niedrigen delay hast du nie gesehen ich habe
es ja auch letztens in battlefield geschafft einen 1er ping zu haben ich
habe nicht nur viele fps ich habe auch noch niedriges delay ich meine irgendwie
muss ich ja meine schlechten reaktionszeiten die ich mittlerweile habe ausgleichen
wissen was das ist was ist das sollte man schreibtisch ein bisschen aufräumen
ich weiß gar nicht wie man das eigentlich nennt so eine kabel ab isoliert zange ist das
kann man nicht erkennen kann man nicht erkennen so möglich am geräusch
es ist einer der man hört es am tag 50 mal oder so wenigstens eine von knippecks ne von
von jokari habe ich noch nie gehört moment jokari tools genau das da
na guck mal das kommt sogar aus deutschland ja produkte und lösungen die da ist es oder
super 4 plus ne super 4 plus die da ist es die da so weg damit oder hätte ich noch
einen billigen china schwachsinn sogar ein echte knippecks isolierdings
netzwerkabel trimmer und gedöns ja egal warum auch das himmel alles rumfliegt so
und zwar was machen wir heute ich habe mir was überlegt und zwar ich habe mir
heute stimmt überhaupt nicht wahrscheinlich hat mir nicht heute ich
habe den gekriegt gestern allerdings bestellt habe ich ihn als einziges bei
dieser amazon cyber monday woche und zwar einen
zwar einen eufy robo wac elf und das ding sieht am gefahr so aus wenn es
fährt so sieht das aus wenn es fährt so mit mit immersive sound experience
so und da ist eine fernbedienung dabei
und die sache ist jetzt die ich muss da jetzt mal mich muss da ein bisschen
ausholen zum erzählen also ihr wisst ja ich habe schon ich baue ja seit einer
weile heim automatisierungstechnik hier daheim auf aus um ja das ist eigentlich
immer irgendwas zu machen und wie gesagt aktuell bin ich an der
gegensprecher lagen von der tür dran aber jetzt so mal als zwischending habe
ich mir gedacht hey gab es bei amazon im angebot 450 euro das ding ist relativ
blöd das kann eigentlich nix großartig das hat allerdings relativ lange akkulaufzeit
und einen relativ großen behälter für den preis also wie gesagt normalerweise
um die 200 euro jetzt gab es bei amazon 450 den der eufy
und habe ich mir gedacht bestellt sind das ding war und das ist so richtig das
ist richtig man würde man würde sagen so ein billig gerät was insofern es hat
keine hersteller hersteller spezifische app es hat kein wlan es hat eigentlich
nix es hat ganz gute akkulaufzeit von irgendwie 100 stunden nicht 100 stunden
100 minuten 100 stunden krass 100 minuten und
ja ein relativ relativ großen behälter hier hinten
du würdest jetzt auch nur kaufen wenn es weep voice hat und wenn das sache können wir abhelfen
und zumindest ist da eine fernbedienung dabei so was richtig also wie gesagt keine
cloud kein wlan keine hersteller app oder sonst was ja auch keine
advanced features wie irgendwie räume abscannen oder sonst irgendwelche
irgendwelche dinger so und die remote genauso sieht die remote aus von dem
ding also das ist ganz billige infrarot fernbedienung ohne irgendwas da habe ich
mir gedacht wir sind mal besonders clever und wir versuchen mit einem raspberry
zero also ist hier wireless ja in zero w so habe ich ja noch einige rumfliegen
habe ich ja schon erzählt da fliegen hier bestimmt noch 20 stück oder so einfach
wir sind halt da ich habe allerdings die variante mit schon vor installiert im header
drauf also gelötet wird jetzt hier nicht mehr heute und und ich habe gesehen also
ich habe vor einer weile schon ein paar infrarot empfänger gekauft so vor zwei
jahren oder so und zwar habe ich hier noch einen
300 er irgendwie so heißt das ding das ding habe ich noch hier das ist so einen
so einen aufsatz wenn das ding jetzt mal das bild laden würde
genau das ist so ein aufsatz für den raspberry da quasi infrarot leds hat oder
halt senden und empfangen kann es mit deswegen habe ich mir jetzt gedacht wir
probieren mal aus übrigens ich werde mal kurz nebenbei wo wir gerade dabei sind
ich ich ich starte mal mein lux vm weil wir brauchen heute wir brauchen auch die
lux vm ein bisschen ich werde jetzt mal versuche ich sage ich die lautstärke
also keiner soll es musik lautstärke ok ich mach mal kurz system update in
zwischenzeit kann man sicher ist sicher während ich hier laber und erzählen darf
da mal kurz updaten man weiß nie ob man das nicht vielleicht doch
brauch hallo kann er zug kann er zug sich mal beenden so ich bin ja doof seine
schleife drumherum da kann sich der zug nicht beenden
moin max hab's endlich in deine streams geschafft auch sehr leis sehr leis
wobei wir heute nicht spielen werden wir werden ein bisschen mit dem raspberry
rum basteln so weiter im text also was wollte ich gerade erzählen es kann man
nicht beenden ich weiß aber ich bin so clever gewesen hat eine schleife drumherum
gemacht das heißt das heißt ich kann so nicht
mal dass das startet sie mal wieder ich bescheuert deswegen muss ich jetzt kann
man das tab killen genau und so ein raspberry habe ich hier ich muss mal
kurz in die kiste wartet mal kisse ich habe jetzt hier schon den raspberry mit
dem energie iow control board habe ich schon zusammengestöpseln auch schon usb
kabel dran wir müssen jetzt bloß wir müssen erst ich
wusste eine micro sd karte nehmen das neue lesbian drauf machen
dann installieren wir das mal und dann probieren wir ob wir es schaffen dem
eufy moment ich mache mal kurz die musik aus ich lasse ich mal kurz hören
also so hört sich das an wenn das ding angeht mal gucken ob ihr das hört
wartet mal leute hört man das
jetzt saugt er und jetzt und jetzt sage ich ihm kehre zu deiner lade station
zurück jetzt hört man jetzt hört man ihn hinterfahren
jetzt hört man ihn zur station fahren leiser weil das sauger aus ist und gleich
macht es klack achtung und jetzt hat er sich angeschlossen leht wieder so und
ich versuche dem dem raspberry quasi jetzt mal also er ist für der ist fürs
erdgeschoss und im erdgeschoss an der eingangstür habe ich eh schon eine
raspberry stecken das heißt das würde sich da wunderbar eignen und da ist da
müssten auch noch die richtigen pins drauf frei sein was fertig nein ich habe
nichts fertig ich habe das auch noch nie gemacht mit wobei noch nie stimmt ich
habe ein bisschen mit rumgespielt aber das habe ich auch genau aus der packung
geholt dass die das bord heute also das habe ich noch nicht gemacht keine ahnung
und dann werde ich versuchen quasi dem dem den raspberry beizubringen den
staubsauger auf automatisches reinigen zu schalten und kehre zurück zur
heimatstation so geht zurück zu haum irgendwie dem diesem infrared blaster
hier beizubringen dass er das machen kann
wo wir das gebacken kriegen weil dann ist das nämlich richtig cool da kann ich
das in mein heim automatisierungssystem integrieren kann ich nämlich sagen ok
wenn das ding gecheckt hat dass ich nicht da bin dann schickt dem olfie eine
nachricht dass jetzt anfangen soll zu putzen
so weit von der theorie das geht natürlich nicht also eingebaut sind die
funktionen relativ rudimentär die dabei sind das ding kann das ding kann ich
zeige ich noch mal wie man also das ding kann im prinzip standardmäßig nicht
allzu viel hier sieht man es man kann dem oben links sagt man dem sagt man dem
kehre zur basis station zurück oben rechts kann zu sagen fahr einfach los und
macht was du willst dann kannst du starten stoppen links rechts kannst du
steuern dann hast du hier kannst du schedule wann das ding das nächste mal
fahren soll hier irgendwie timer an aus er soll einen speziellen punkt reinigen
er soll einen raum reinigen er soll irgendwie so viel wie es geht an fläche
oder so reinigen soll die ecken reinigen wie so kannst du es machen
sollen wir versuchen im raspberry die funktionen für diese tast und die
funktionen für diese taste beizubringen weil das ist im endeffekt an und fahr
einfach rum und mach und das hier ist im prinzip geht zurück zur basis so
anders das muss man im raspberry beibringen dass der das eben als
infrarot kommandos sendet an den olfie das probieren wir mal aus heute
ja genau der kehrt zurück der wenn er leer wird sucht er sich die basis station
und fährt zurück ist das jetzt ein raspberry staubsauger so halb kannst du
mal ein home des des des des des des des des des des des des des des des des
die warnverbindung drinne da sind die leute also es ist zu viel zeug kann ich
machen ich habe überlegt ob ich mir nicht vielleicht irgendwie eine home
assistant vm oder so mache dass wir noch die integration in home system uns
angucken können
das könnte man machen wir könnten uns nicht mehr könnten uns ein lxd
container mit home assistant installieren und dass dann er
irgendwie einbinden oder so das können wir machen
ja das müsste funktionieren so
ich glaube ich könnte das noch mal auf so ja kommt scheiß drauf
ich kann das noch mal auf twitter posten muss nicht sein genau so haben
ich update gemacht
gut das erste was wir machen müssen ist jetzt erst mal relativ langweilig und
zwar müssen erst mal auf dem raspberry das neue raspian download das neue
raspian installieren dass wir was machen können
worum geht es genau naja wie gesagt ich zeige sie noch mal ich habe mir einen
staubsauger gekauft und zwar den hier ein olfie robowag 11
und der kann halt nix im endeffekt smart ist der hat keine app vom
hersteller da hat keine hat eigentlich nix der hat im prinzip nur
fernbedienung wir probiere den raspberry jetzt bei ich habe so einen bord hier mal
vor ein paar jahren gekauft wenn das bei die wo man infrarot kommandos schicken
kann ich versuche jetzt mal irgendwie beizubringen dass der dem olfie sagt geht
zur heimatstation zurück und fahr los also ich erzähl mal auf was für ein
eisnach im haumassistent hast also ich habe einmal was einmal ganz cool ist für
morgen so ein report so nach dem motto wie viel viel zu später zug ist ob
irgendwie post post kommt oder irgendwie so so gedöns ja wie das wetter wird
selbst zusammen gebastelt und ich formatier mal die die karte in der
zwischenzeit schon wir laden jetzt erst mal das neueste respiren runter aber
das coolste was ich habe ist ich habe eine lampe immer so eine so eine so eine
so eine rgb lampe wo man halt farbe ändern kann letztendlich ich glaube
helligkeit kann man damit auch aber ich erinnere ich erinnere nur farbe und die
farbe der lampe die ist quasi auf dem weg ins bad morgens morgens und die hier
download und die farbe der lampe ändert sich je nachdem wie viel verspätung man
zug hat also sprich da muss man nicht mal auf die app morgens gucken man stream
ordner da muss man nicht mal in muss man nicht mal auf die app morgens gucken
dass ich direkt anhand der lampe wenn der zug verspätung hat das ist eine ganz
coole anwendung eigentlich das ist eigentlich auch super super einfach
gemacht weil du hast hier in haumassistent also man könnte das einfach
man könnte das komplett selbst machen aber das schöne ist dass es in
haumassistent schon ein bahnsensor gibt und da gibt es da einfach ein stellst du
einfach die haumassistent macht die macht die komponente rein sagt hier
einfach from gibst du deinen halt an wo du wo du herkommst wo du hin willst dann
sagst du only direkt weil sonst spuckt er mir sonst was wie für verbindung aus
dem bus und sonst was und dann sagt er dir wie spät das was wie viel verspätung
das ganze hat und dann kannst du halt drauf reagieren oder sagst dann ok wenn
verspätung über fünf minuten dann macht die rampe lampe orange über zehn
minuten macht die lampe rot irgendwie sowas wie du willst eigentlich das ist
wirklich ganz nützlich so respiren hat es jetzt umgelaudet
ja gut dann probieren sie hier meinen usb sd karten redors und den stöpsel
melzmann moment ich war mal die musik wieder an
ja gleich viel besser so ich stöpsel mein sd karten wieder rein kennt ihr das
dass man usb sticks immer falsch rum rein steckt links rum rechts rum rechts
rum geht nicht links rum rechts rum links jetzt gehts immer immer der
kleine scheiß ja ja so was haben wir hier stb 1 ok da ist schon irgendwas drauf
wurscht hauen wir einfach weg übrigens bestes bestes formatierungstool wie ich
finde hier etcher in der heutigen zeit man könnte auch einfach drauf den ja in
der heutigen zeit hat man natürlich schon eine komplette elektron anwendung
rein fürs flaschen von einer sd karte die auch einfach so schon mal irgendwie
keine 130 mb ram verbraucht einfach nur weil sie offen ist aber so sind
elektron anwendung downloads respiren select drive 100 128 gig sd karte
sd karten habe ich euch die story habe ich auch schon erzählt mit amazon und
der sd karten packung oder bla bla bla habe ich jetzt auch das richtige sdb sd
trance sind ja kontinue also sd karten mangel werde ich die nächsten jahre
nicht haben
sd karten mangel welche werde ich in nächster zeit nicht haben amazon hat mir
irgendwann ich habe ich habe sd karten bestellt und hat mir amazon anstatt
einer karte haben die mir so ein packen geschickt mit 20 karten oder so drinne
und auch auch die guten die hat man wo habe ich es denn hier mit 32 gig hier
jetzt ist ein kompletter karten mit sd karten also micro sd karten und ich
habe mir gedacht ich habe schon so viel bei amazon bestellt wenn die sich
verschicken ist sonst noch nicht vorgekommen dann hat man amazon hat pech
gehabt warum soll ich das zurückschicken das sind die guten samsung 32 g
micro sd karten da ist jetzt irgendwie noch 20 stücke oder so das reicht jetzt
was war denn mit amazon die amazon hat mir anstatt eine karte den ganzen pack
geschickt hat der typ gedacht der maxer braucht das und hat es einfach
reingefärfert ins paket frag mich nicht warum ich meine ich habe so viel
kohle schon bei amazon ausgegeben ich glaube ein paar sd karten werden sie
jetzt nicht kann in den ruinen treiben irgendwie
es geht die musik ab
oh guck mal ist mir ein bord back drum
ich bin aus irgendwelchen gründen den firefox ein
ist es geflasht noch dauert noch
aber wir können wenn ihr wollt uns noch mal den home assistant installieren hier
in a4m und gucken wie wir das wie wir den raspberry später einbinden soll wir
das machen also hier also quasi das was ich als
home automatisierungslösung verwende wir können uns das in a4m installieren und
dann binden wir den raspberry ein wenn wir es hingekriegt haben installation
on your computer blub blub blub
ne ich will es nicht ich will es braucht kein virtual n ne das da ist doch sogar
das richtige
ja so so sieht es aus wenn es einfach nur da ist
aber jetzt das ist schon wieder aus die kiste ich ich installiere mir hier
relativ oft ich installiere mir hier relativ oft drauf einen home assistant
zu rumbasteln dass ich an meiner an meiner eigentlichen command line switch
shell command das brauchen wir auf jeden fall gleich noch
ja ich installiere mir hier öfters mal was drauf um halt meine normale
home assistant instanzen an der nicht rumbasteln zu müssen
so war er jetzt mit flaschen fertig war er mit flaschen fertig
ich habe jetzt nicht geguckt war er fertig ich habe glaube ich einfach zugemacht
habt ihr gesehen ob der fertig flaschen war
gucken wir mal
war er fertig mount mount stb1 kommt hin ja
ja ja das sieht gut aus touch ssh so und jetzt muss ich euch ausmachen weil
jetzt muss ich meine jetzt muss ich meinen wlan passport und gedöns eintippen
ich muss das gerade noch kurz gucken wie das wie das ging stretch
muss ich immer nachgucken
immer das kann ich mir nie merken
ja also nur mal zur erklärung also für alle die die vielleicht sich auch mal
ein raspberry kaufen wollte ich habe mir auch mal ein raspberry gekauft
für alle die die vielleicht sich auch mal ein raspberry kaufen wollen und so ein
bisschen guide brauchen wie das funktioniert also eigentlich super
simpel wie ich gezeigt habe man lädt sich hier das offizielle raspian image
runter ich nehme immer das da ist keine grafische
oberflasche und gedöns dabei weil ich habe da eh kein monitor dran
angeschlossen
lädt sich das runter nimmt sich etcher und flasht das damit auf die sd karte
und danach und das ist jetzt ein schritt den braucht man eigentlich nur beim
zero in der form und vor allem auch nur wenn man den eben ohne monitor und
tastatur betreibt das erste was man macht ist man geht auf die sd karte das
jetzt ich bin hier das ist der inhalt von der sd karte und erstellt darin eine
datei die sich ssh nennt dann startet der raspberry startet automatisch ssh
und könnt ihr euch remote darauf einloggen so und als nächstes braucht
ihr das hier was was was der dude hier schreibt ihr müsst eine datei anlegen
die sich wpa supplikant punkt konfront und den schmodder hier reinkopieren
auch alles auf der sd karte drauf und da gibt ihr dann eure eure wlan
bezeichnung ein also wie das wlan heißt und euer wlan passwort und das da
unten stimmt denn in der regel hast du wpa pre-shared key pre-shared key ist
im prinzip ein anderes wort für passwort
so und jetzt muss ich euch mal kurz ausschalten weil
muss ich mal kurz ausschalten weil ich muss meinen passport eingeben und das
wollen wir ja nicht das
habe ich mich
ok gut kann er wieder einschalten
so ne ne psk steht für pre-shared key also quasi passwort so jetzt gehe ich hier
gleich wieder raus dass ich gar nicht auf die blöde idee kommt da irgendwie
die passwort datei anzuzeigen sonst muss ich meinen wlan passwort ändern
so und immer ganz wichtig wenn man auf sd karten was macht an mal unten und am
besten noch mal einen zynk hinterher hauen das ist quasi im prinzip das was
was windows macht wenn ihr sagt sicher entfernen so ungefähr und normalerweise
sage ich brauchst du das nicht unbedingt aber bei bei sd karten würde ich da
drauf gucken
krieg seance könnte ich machen könnte ich mal aber das geht immer so schnell
das ist eine sache von fünf minuten habe ich noch keinen das ist ja triplon
übelst geilen 123 leute ohne ankündigung und irgendwas sehr sehr nice ist schön
dass ihr alle da seid und mir zuguckt wie ich meinen staubsauger robot haben
im raspberry fernsteuer auch null ok ich mache jetzt mal usb stick ab also den
usb stick karten reader für die sd karte so ich habe jetzt hier mein raspberry
ich kann euch das jetzt leider nicht zeigen aber ich meine es ist also
wahrscheinlich jeder den raspberry in hand gehabt hat auch schon gesehen
ich zeige es jetzt bloß mal für alle die sie noch nicht gesehen haben also so
sieht er aus mit so sieht er aus und da kommt die sd karte rein das heißt ich
nehme jetzt die 128 sd karte micro sd karte
und führe sie dem raspberry ein so es hängt so dran das bord ist auch schon
oben drauf also sprich das ding hier 128 g ist die erste sd karte hier noch
umgelegen hat final würde ich da keine 128 g für ein raspberry pie nehmen weil
da kommt ja lokal nichts drauf so die karte habe ich schon genommen und oben
auf die pins gesteckt wohlgemerkt beim raspberry 0 ist es umgedreht wenn der
normalen raspberry habt ist hier 0 1 beim 0 ist hier 0 1 also die karten
müssen quasi immer genau auf die entgegengesetzte seite bei einem normalen
raspberry bei dem 0 weißt du was ich nicht verstehe ist warum war auf diesem
bord kein platz mehr hier hinzuschreiben 0 das weiß ich warum er das nicht
hingekriegt hat dann würde es viel weniger verwirrung geben und viel weniger
kaputte geräte gut ich stöpsel den mal ein und hoffe er bootet
oh fuck ist er runter gefallen monkaS monka giga ok ich stöpsel den raspberry
mal ein hier strom versorgen gucken wir mal ob er angeht oder abbraucht oder
was auch immer er macht ja er geht an das ist schon mal gut
dann gucke ich mal kurz was auf meinem router guck mal nach was der für eine ip
gekriegt hat was hier services dhcp locks ist noch nicht da ja und dann
loggen wir uns jetzt per ssh drauf ein und gucken mal wie wir das hinkriegen dem
ding irgendwie infrarot kommandos beizubringen die musik ist ein ticken
laut oder was hast du für einen router aktuell habe ich noch pf sens kannst
den prinzip mal zeigen ich kann es dir eigentlich mal zeigen
so guck hier da ist der raspberry das ist pf sens router aktuell ist noch wie
gesagt noch ein selbst gebasteltes pf sens so hier ist die ip die der raspberry
gekriegt hat die kopieren wir uns jetzt mal raus und da mache ich hier immer
wieder meine router machen wir wieder zu ich persönlich bin ja eher für die
aussprache router aber ich weiß dass ganz viele leute gibt die quasi bei der
straße ja also bei ist es die route die man fährt am meck liegt oh mein gott
hakt hakt wollte jetzt sagen aber irgendwie beim router sagen ganz viele
den tunkel ja dass er es merkt hat sein kann so heißt die kiste swift range punkt in
natürlich ist er hier drin zeile 15
so zeile 15 ist weg
jetzt kommen wir uns per ssh drauf verbinden
das ding ist am anfang immer ein bisschen lahm da macht immer am anfang update
versuchte man paket updates zu machen sowas deswegen ist der raspberry übelste
übrigens standard passport ist beim raspberry ist bei allen ist standard user
ist pie und standard passport ist raspberry was wird das das wird eine
fernsteuerung für meinen staubsauger robotter
ach wieder da haben sie schon wieder hast du wieder kommandos gemacht was es
heute geht meine mods haben es drauf ja um den hier
nicht lernen aber von jetzt auf gleich wissen das ist doch auch langweilig so
einfach instant knowledge das macht ja auch spaß wenn man dinger lernt wenn sie
einem gefallen wohlgemerkt die meisten sachen die man lernen muss gefallen
nicht das ist das problem deswegen haben die meisten leute kein bock was zu
lernen wenn man was lernt in dem gebiet was einem spaß macht was einem gefällt
dann macht das lernen eigentlich fast mehr spaß als das das was später weiß
aber die meisten sachen gehen dann halt auf den sack niemand lernen muss
so ach ja genau stimmt weil grad da vorne enthalten fragt vielleicht soll ich
sie so ein bisschen genauer klären also wir haben jetzt ja ich logg mich noch
kurz aus also wir haben jetzt ja die sd karte von raspberry fertig gemacht und
die sd karte in raspberry gestöpseln in raspberry eingeschaltet und wir haben
ihm gesagt hier wlan konfiguration haben wir eingetragen und ganz wichtig touch
ssh und touch ssh auf der sd karte sorgt dafür dass der raspberry ssh
startet und ssh ist für die leute die sich die nicht so mit linux ja nicht so
nicht so gut mit linux auskennen dann kann man sagen das ist ein bisschen wie
der vergleich ist eigentlich voll von arsch aber ich sag mal das einzige was
die windows leute kennen ist ein bisschen wie remote desktop für windows
bloß ohne den desktop anteil es ist also eigentlich eher remote powershell wenn
man es so will wenn man das mal mit windows begriffen sprechen möchte ssh ist
ein ist ein weg wie ich remote verschlüsselt gesichert auf meine
linux systeme zugreifen kann zum beispiel kann es euch mal zeigen
ich kann es euch nicht zeigen weil die kiste abgekackt ist ich habe mir nämlich
ich habe mir den server gemietet für ein paar dollars ich wollte mich da gerade
drauf einloggen und sagen guck mal hier der server steht quasi irgendwo in der
wallerei irgendwo am arsch der welt problem ist bloß die kiste ist abgekackt
ich habe es noch nicht neu gestartet deswegen wird das ganze auch nichts mit
einloggen naja zumindest ist im prinzipie egal ob ich mich per ssh auf
einem raspberry einlogger der neben mir steht oder per ssh auf eine kiste die in
usbekistan oder irgendwie im chat oder so steht weiß man dann nicht
ja genau und ssh ist halt im vergleich zu remote desktop von windows
ist ssh halt rein kommando zeilen basiert so wir haben mal in meinem router
nachgeguckt der raspberry hat die hat diese ip gekriegt und der standard user
ist halt pie und der standard password ist raspberry
so vor einem titan hat man das verstanden soweit was ich erklärt habe
darauf sollte eigentlich jetzt klar sein so wenn man dann auf dem raspberry drauf
ist ich bin jetzt eingeloggt auf dem raspberry im unteren tab bin ich bei mir
lokal im ordner stream und oben bin ich auf dem raspberry so könnte man über
ssh auch oft seit nass backups machen ja klar klar dann würde ich aber erst
verwendet erst über ssh weil er so handelt für dich schon dass es die
dateien nicht doppelt überträgt und diffs und sowas wobei es dafür schönere
varianten gibt aber ja du kannst mit ssh auch dateien kopieren bzw. mit scp
man könnte der rüppel hat recht man könnte sich auch seinen gui umleiten
ich versuche euch das mal zu zeigen ich versuche euch mal zu zeigen dass man über
ssh nicht nur kommando zeile verwenden kann sondern auch grafische programme
installieren jetzt mal das billigste grafische programm was es so gibt für
linux an die x11 apps ist es ich hoffe das funktioniert einfach so es kann sein
dass ich noch mehr installieren muss da lasse ich bleiben
es kann sein dass ich x-formen überhaupt das einschalten muss kann sein dass es
standardmäßig gar nicht an ist
ja ja und der andere leech hat recht das ist auch eine sehr schöne geschichte
das verwende ich auch öfters du kannst ja auch quasi von einem remote system
quasi nen ordner bei dir lokal verknüpfen ja das ist ein bisschen so wie
bisschen so wie wenn man unter windows sich den netzlaufwerk als irgendwie w
doppelpunkten und so einbinden das geht auch das ist das ist richtig praktisch
ja also ssh ist generell also ssh kennen und nicht kennen macht sehr viel aus
man kann mit ssh ssh so viel dinger drehen man kann mit ssh sich zum
beispiel auch porz tunnel ganz abgedrehtes zeug also ssh ist wirklich so
ein tun mit dem man fast alles machen kann so ich versuche mal auf dem
respekt jetzt xis zu installieren und dann remote zu starten mal gucken ob das
funktioniert wenn das funktioniert werdet ihr sehen dass wir nicht nur
kommando zeile machen kann so wir müssen allerdings als erstes mal gucken ob x
forwarding überhaupt also übrigens das erste wenn man auf dem dealungssystem
ist wenn installieren t max installieren wichtigste wichtigste sache
überhaupt t max ist das was ihr hier seht mit den mit den tabs unten
tabs spitten so spitten so spitten so spitten hin und her tappen dazwischen
ja das braucht man eigentlich immer das habe ich jetzt halt hier lokal das ist
zum beispiel ganz praktisch geht man davon mal genommen ich editiere jetzt
hier was man es feigen was was was t max macht und ich will auf der seite gucken
wie die auslastung von meinem system ist da kann ich halt hier zeug machen und
rechts und rechts gucken dabei eigentlich ganz ganz nützlich da kann
ich sagen ok jetzt machen wir mal was was ein bisschen ein bisschen auslastung
generiert irgendwie bc blau irgendwas ausrechnen
kauten guck und jetzt bäm 99 prozent cpu lasst wir machen das ganze mal wieder aus
das ist halt sehr praktisch mit t max tabs tabs tabs
was ist eigentlich die mehrzahl von nas nasse wahrscheinlich auf englisch
nassos oder irgendwie sowas mal tippe nassos keine ahnung schon nie überlegt
was die mehrzahl von das ist ok also ich zeige euch das jetzt mal mit dem
grafischen programm
x x vor allen Dingen ist enable ok also es müsste funktionieren kann sein dass
es nicht funktioniert also man kann wie gesagt man kann sich per ssh einloggen
und dann hat man halt eine kommando zeile
so man kann aber auch sagen ssh-y früher war es minus x aber minus y ist die
advanced variante davon und wenn man dann alles richtig konfiguriert hat auf dem
server kann man auch grafische programme weiterleiten
so x-eis zum beispiel bäm ich sagte x-eis man sieht auch wie sie ruckelt dass es
nicht bei mir lokal ist also x-eis ist immer ein gutes programm um grafische
sachen zu testen weil es ist das billigste grafische programm was es
ever was es gibt ja und nur zur erklärung dass es das ist übrigens auch
rtx on enabled x-eis ja als neue testament schreibt gerade im chat das
hört sich irgendwie blöd an das neue testament schreibt gerade im chat
und dieses grafische programm läuft jetzt auf meinem raspberry allerdings
wird die grafische ausgabe umgebogen dass es jetzt bei mir lokal angezeigt
wird ihr seht das programm habe ich auf dem raspberry ausgeführt also man kann
auch grafische programme über ssh weiterleiten aber man sollte keine
performance wunder irgendwie erwarten ich gehe links hier ist drauf also es ist
es ist eigentlich für nichts zu gebrauchen was grafisch irgendwie ein
bisschen aufwendiger ist x-forwarding ist komplett useless dafür aber sich in
den browser weiter zu leiten oder sowas ja dafür ist das ganz gut und viele
sachen geht es halt darum dass sie überhaupt funktionieren nicht dass sie
schnell funktionieren so habe ich irgendwas überlesen welches tool benutzt du eigentlich
für die firm das ist vor allem bei workstation noch irgendwie die
vorletzte version oder sowas ok weiter gehts im text also wir haben den
raspberry installiert wir haben das infrarot modul oben drauf wir machen
upgrade dass wir auch die letzte paketversion drauf haben
er hat schon geupgrade vielleicht mal schon mal update vorher aber das macht
er in der regel nach dem installieren automatisch einmal
was benutzt du für software also beispielsweise java python gerade gar
nichts hat es immer einfach per ssh auf raspberry eingeloggt hat das raspberry
genügend leistung um es als office pc zu verwenden also der zero auf gar keinen
fall zero kannst vergessen für sowas der normale raspberry hat genug leistung
allerdings nur wenn man ein bisschen warten kann
es ist man muss sagen für das was in dem raspberry drinne ist ist der desktop
doch noch erstaunlich schnell aber es du kannst es halt nicht mit normalen
desktop system vergleichen ich meine wenn du das mit normalen desktop system
vergleicht irgendwie so aktuellen reisen oder so nimmst du den allerkleinsten
reisen und der steckt halt jeden raspberry zu keine ahnung zu 3000
prozent schneller in die tasche oder so wenn es mal reicht wenn es mal reicht
wahrscheinlich 30.000 prozent also keine wobei so schlecht sind die armen
dinge auch gar nicht
ja kannst du machen also wie gesagt du kannst ausprobieren ob das passt
ich würde aber den ich würde aber den den den neuesten nehmen wenn es irgendwie
geht also der mit fake gigabit und und sowas ja das sind armen chips wobei das
wobei das beim raspberry ein bisschen also die die die architektur vom raspberry
an sich ist nicht so schön das sind zwar normale armen chips aber da ist noch
proprietäre ich glaube procom firmware und sowas drum also so offen wie das der
anschein hat ist der raspberry gar nicht da sind andere sachen besser hackbar als
der raspberry so was haben jetzt so wir haben die pakete geupgradet sonst was
ok und jetzt probieren wir mal einen infrarot kommando dem ding irgendwie zu
entlocken da muss ich jetzt gucken wie das geht
es bergpil
so man hat ja noch bestimmt eine anleitung dafür
Die haben auch bestimmt eine Anleitung dafür.
Die haben auch bestimmt eine Anleitung für Product Instructions.
Also, was muss man machen? Wie gesagt, das Ding hab ich oben draufgestöpselt.
Was hältst du von risk v? Kann ich gar nichts zu sagen.
Genau, das ist noch der normale Raspberry, nicht der Zero. Den hab ich angeschlossen, passt.
Ähm, ich guck mal kurz, ob man hier irgendwas drinne sieht.
Äh, ER.
Steht da nichts von.
Doch, hier, guck mal.
ER?
Erkennt er da irgendwelche Infrarotgeschichten oder steht das immer da? Weiß ich gar nicht.
So, okay.
Das ist die offizielle Anleitung zu diesem komischen Infrarot-Senderempfänger, den ich auf den Raspberry draufgestöpselt hab.
Also, als erstes soll man LIRC installieren.
Ja, das ist dieses Linux, dieser Linux-Infrarot-Demon, den stimmt, den hab ich schon mal irgendwann gesehen.
LIRC, installieren wir LIRC, das hört sich auch wieder an, ey. LIRC.
Lässt dich so ein Pi mit einem Arduino koppeln, kommt drauf an, wie du den koppeln willst.
Über das Netzwerk, also überhaupt kein Problem.
Die sprechen ja alle das gleiche Netzwerk-Protokoll.
Ansonsten, die Pins kannst du auch koppeln, ja, wenn die Spannung stimmt.
Ähm, die Frage, was du machen willst.
Nee, nee, ähm, der, natürlich kann der saugen, der Roboter, sonst wär's ja kein Staubsauger-Roboter, äh, Junghorn.
Das ist, natürlich kann der saugen, aber der kann ansonsten nix, der hat keine Smart-Funktionen vom Hersteller.
Also da spricht halt keine Hersteller-App, ähm, und kein WLAN und sonst was.
So, ähm, der hat halt eine Fernbedienung dabei, so eine altertümliche Infrarot-Fernbedienung.
Das Ding hier, und ich hab mir vor zwei Jahren oder so mal für einen Raspberry so einen Infrarot-Senderempfänger gekauft.
Das Ding hier. Und wir versuchen jetzt mal dem Raspberry beizubringen, dass der meinen Euphi steuern kann.
Wir machen erstmal nur, ähm, putzen, starten und zurück zur Basisstation.
Was geht denn mit der Musik? Weiß ich nicht. Ist die irgendwie kaputt?
Ist die kaputt? Nö, bei mir heute ist es schon normaler.
So, ähm, wie geht denn das jetzt weiter?
Setup GPIOs pins to use. Blablabla. Modprobe. Etc-Modules. Ah, Modules. Etc-Modules.
Das ist, was für Kernel-Module geladen werden beim Start und mit welchen Parametern.
Ja, es ist ja so, dass, ähm, du kannst entweder Sachen fest in den Linuskernlein kompilieren, aber das macht man eigentlich nicht mehr so gerne.
Oder aber als Kernel-Modul, was man lädt bei Bedarf.
Wie willst du das denn machen? Den Raspberry auf dem Staubsauger packen?
Nee, ich werd den, ähm, den Raspberry quasi in Flur stellen, gegenüber, also schräg gegenüber von der Basisstation, vom Euphi.
Und ich werd dem einfach sagen, Start. Und dann werd ich das Stop-Kommando alle 5 Minuten oder so mal wiederholen, wenn er stoppen soll.
Alternativ kehrt das Ding ja auch selbst zur Basisstation zurück, wenn er leer ist.
Mir geht's hauptsächlich darum, dass ich den starten kann.
Und theoretisch könnte ich auch die Steuerung übers Tablet machen, aber es bringt mir ja nichts, wenn ich es nicht sehe.
Hauptsächlich geht's mir darum, dass ich das von meinem Smart-Home-System anschalten kann.
Da kann ich nämlich sagen, okay, Max ist jetzt nicht daheim, sonst auch keiner daheim.
Und, äh, dann schicke mal Start.
Die neuen Thinkpads sind die Lenovo-Dinger, oder? Keine Ahnung, hab ich noch nicht verwendet.
So, ähm, wie geht's denn jetzt weiter?
Edit your LIRC-Hardware-Konf. Ähm, ja, das können wir dann mal irgendwann machen. Erstmal gucken wir mal, ob wir irgendwie...
LIRC soll gestoppt werden, okay.
Ja, das ist vollkommener Blödsinn.
Oh, die Anleitung ist aber schon ganz schön alt.
Die Anleitung ist schon ganz schön alt.
Ich glaube, die wird's so nicht mehr tun. Da müssen wir gleich mal nach was neuerem suchen.
Was ist jetzt los, Hippogro?
Wenn du erfolgreich bist, würdest du dann das Programm verkaufen?
Ähm, ich glaube nicht, dass man da viel machen muss. Also kannst du das ohne Probleme so machen, wie wir hier im Stream machen.
Ich werde jetzt einfach, ich werde jetzt versuchen, es wird ja kein großartiges, kompliziertes Programm.
Ach so, du hast jetzt das gesehen. Jetzt check ich's. MonkaS, MonkaGiga.
Ähm, ich benutze ja was, was fertig ist, ja, und lerne dem Ding einfach die Tastendrücke.
Oh, das ist schlecht.
Das ist schlecht, wenn du irgendwelche Kindle-Module laden willst,
und er sagt, er kann nicht, das ist meistens schlecht. Das ist wirklich, äh, okay, die Anleitung ist einfach zu alt.
Die Anleitung ist wahrscheinlich von, haben die irgendwie ein Datum hier drinne stehen?
2014, 2015, 2016, 17, 18, okay, die haben kein Datum drinstehen.
Aber ich glaube, die Anleitung ist einfach zu alt. Wir werden jetzt einfach mal googeln.
Ähm, Raspberry, äh, äh, da.
Wer, wer mit Linux was macht, bzw. wer mit, äh, bisschen Heimautomatisierung und Raspberries rumbastelt,
der braucht auf jeden Fall gute Google-Skills, sonst wird das Ganze nix.
Blalalala, GPU are not supported anymore for Raspberry Pi 2, äh, aha.
Wir geben jetzt noch mal GitHub dabei ein, ob wir noch eine, noch eine Erklärung kriegen.
Lirk, get a Lirk to work with Raspberry Pi 3, das geht für den Zero bestimmt auch.
Hast du eigentlich das Kameramodul für den Pi, ja.
Haben wir sogar in dem Stream hier schon mal, äh, eingerichtet, die Katzencam, Katzencam im Häuschen, wo sie immer liegt.
Okay, GPU are not supported anymore for Raspberry Pi 2, ähm, ah.
Können wir in die System-Messages gucken.
Und da sehen wir, wir haben ziemlich genau die gleiche Fehlermeldung, die der Dude auf GitHub auch hat.
You should use forums, bla, bla, bla, add, add DT-Overlay, was?
Was soll ich machen?
In boot-config soll ich eintragen DT-Overlay, okay.
Deswegen als erstes immer WIM installieren.
DT-Overlay.
Ach guck mal, da steht es ja sogar schon drinnen.
Uncomment this to enable Lirk-Modul.
Bam.
Ja, dann machen wir das doch, das werden wir rebooten.
Nach so Modulkram immer rebooten.
Ich bin langsam am Kopf, wehe, was ist denn los?
Okays.
Wenn wir gerade dabei sind.
Monkeis, Monkeis, Monkeis, Monkeis, Monkeis, Monkeis, Monkeis, Monkeis, Monkeis.
Ahjajaja.
So, hat er neu gestartet.
150 Leute, die mir zugucken, wie ich meinen Staubsauger verbaut habe, mit dem Raspberry Fernsteuer.
Nice, schön, dass ihr alle dabei seid.
So.
Mod-Pro-Lirk.
Ah.
Das ist schon mal gut.
So, und jetzt machen wir das mal testing.
Testing, wo war, wo stand das jetzt?
Hier, testing receiver.
Erstmal Lirk stoppen. Achja.
System CTL stopp.
Und jetzt, ja, das haben wir auch schon gerade gemacht.
Und jetzt, was auch immer.
Aha, guck mal, der liest was.
Er liest angeblich irgendwelche Dinge von der Infrarot-Schnittstelle, die gar nicht sein können, weil...
Ja, keine Ahnung, weil ich nichts drücke.
Das ist schon mal, ich glaube, da stimmt irgendwas mit den Settings nicht.
Ich meine, warum liest er was, wenn es nichts zu lesen gibt, ne?
Ah, guck mal.
Ach, ich drücke jetzt mal einen Knopf auf meiner Fernbedienung.
Okay.
Also, der liest schon irgendwas, ich weiß bloß nicht so genau was, um ehrlich zu sein.
Was soll das Programm am Ende machen, meinen Staubsauger-Roboter fernsteuern?
Aber das wird kein Programm, das wird eine Config für Lirk wahrscheinlich,
wo ich dann von meinem Heim-Automatisierungs-Hub quasi ein Kommando schicken kann,
eufi, fahr los.
Okay, das funktioniert nicht.
Gucken wir uns mal die Anleitung von dem Typ hier an, ob das besser ist.
Er ist neun Tage alt, scheint relativ aktuell zu sein.
Haben wir gemacht.
Das haben wir nicht gemacht, das sah anders aus bei uns.
Modules.
Moment, ne, ne, ne.
Das ist doch genau das, was wir eingetragen haben.
Okay, passt.
Dann müssen wir doch nichts machen.
Add following lines to etc-lirk-hardware-conf.
Gut, machen wir.
Ob das sagt, ich weiß zwar nicht, was es bewirkt, aber wenn es hilft, dann machen wir das.
Update your following.
Ah, siehste, das haben wir auch nicht.
Das sieht anders aus bei uns.
Update lirk options.
So, was sollen wir update in driver auf default?
Frag mich nicht, was ich hier mache.
Ich mach einfach das, was in der Anleitung steht.
Device auf lirk 0.
Starten, stoppen.
Moment.
Warum geht das jetzt?
Das ist doch alles, was wir eben auch gemacht haben.
Starten, stoppen.
Okay.
Status.
Running.
Okay.
Reboot.
Okay, Reboot.
Reboot tut immer gut.
Welchen Win-off-Manager benutzt wir gerade?
Das ist i3.
I3 mit Gaps.
Die Gaps bringen nichts, aber sie sehen gut aus.
Gaps.
Also im Prinzip habe ich auch noch die ersten drei Desktops durchnummeriert.
Browser, Terminal, Editor.
Mehr braucht man nicht.
Damit kommst du eigentlich in 99% der Fälle immer zurecht.
Die anderen Desktops sind quasi optional.
Die brauch ich nicht.
Plus 1, 2, 3 sind durchnummeriert.
So, hat er neu gestartet.
Raspberry.
Ach so.
Übrigens auch mal für die Leute, die, wie gesagt, nicht so viel Mithilfungs machen.
Was ihr machen könnt ist, es geht einem jetzt ja ziemlich auf den Sack,
dass man jedes Mal das Passwort eingeben muss.
Ihr könnt auch SSH Copy ID machen.
So.
Dann gebt ihr einmal noch das Passwort ein.
Und jetzt, zeige ich es euch mal.
Und jetzt braucht ihr nie wieder ein Passwort eingeben.
Ihr habt jetzt nämlich euren SSH Public Key auf dem Raspberry hinzugefügt,
dass ihr euch quasi per Key identifizieren wollt und nicht per Passwort.
Zockst du auch on stream? Ja.
Das letzte, was wir gespielt haben.
Oder, das nächste, was ich noch spielen muss,
weil das hat in der Umfrage gewonnen, ist das erste Bad Company Singleplayer.
So.
Und jetzt können wir angeblich, das haben wir Reboot gemacht.
Jetzt müssen wir Lirk wieder stoppen.
Und danach müssen wir hier gucken, ob wir unsere Fernbedienung erkennen.
Oh fuck, mein Raspberry fällt gleich runter.
Quickmuffs.
Nicht runterfallen, ich muss da mal was drauflegen.
Oh, okay.
Sodass der den Euphi sieht.
Sehr schön. Okay.
Kann sowas, so kann ein Raspberry auch abstürzen.
Ja, wenn er vom Tisch fällt, ist nicht so schlimm.
Also generell sind die Raspberries an sich eigentlich relativ resistent gegen runterfallen,
weil die so leicht sind.
Und wenn die im Gehäuse sind, erst recht.
Das Problem ist beim Raspberry, dass er sich relativ schnell kurzschließen kann an irgendwas.
Wenn das Ding auf der falschen Unterlage liegt, instant RIP.
vor allem der Zero.
Der Zero hat auch nicht mal so einen Überspannungsschutz oder sonst was.
Der Zero ist einfach instant RIP, wenn da irgendwie was ist.
Okay, und jetzt können wir mal gucken, ob wir...
Ah, das sieht schon besser aus.
So Leute, ich drücke jetzt mal Knöpfe.
Ui, ui.
Boah, der Euphi fährt los.
Ja klar, wenn ich auf der Fernbedienung rumdrücke, ist ja klar, dass der losfährt.
Aber ihr seht...
So, geh mal wieder heim, Euphi.
Euphi, deine Station ist hinter dir und nicht vor dir.
Ja, fahr zu deiner Station.
So ist fein.
Fahr zu deiner Station.
Gut.
Also, ihr habt gesehen, das Ding erkennt meine Tastendrücke.
Ja.
So, und jetzt müssen wir nur mal gucken, wie wir dem Ding irgendwie beibringen können,
dass er Tastendrücke aufzeichnet.
Das dürfte, hoffe ich mal, nicht allzu...
Wie findet der Robo seine Ladestation auch über IR?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Wahrscheinlich.
Erschreckt die Katze nicht, dann hast du den letzten Stream nicht mitgekriegt.
Bei dem letzten Stream hab ich gesagt, dass es die Katze nicht mehr gibt.
Die Katze, die gibt's nicht mehr.
Die zweite Katze war das ja schon.
Die erste Katze war ja das.
Und das war die zweite.
Aber die gibt's nicht mehr.
Was ist mit der Katze?
Die war krank.
Die hatte Nierenprobleme.
Das wusste man, dass die es nicht mehr allzu lange hat.
Aber das ging jetzt doch relativ überraschend schnell.
Ich hätte jetzt auch nicht gedacht, dass das so schnell geht.
Die hat jetzt quasi acht Wochen kaum was gefressen.
Hat immer nur...
Ich kann euch das mal zeigen.
Das ist echt nicht schlecht als Ergänzungsfutter.
Nee.
Die hat quasi nur noch das hier gefuttert.
Das ist so eine...
So was für Nierenkranke Katzen, dass sie eigentlich wieder Appetit kriegen sollen.
Aber sie hat zwar gefuttert, aber Appetit hat sie davor nicht mehr gekriegt.
Und letzte Woche Freitag.
Und letzte Woche Donnerstag.
War sie dann so fertig schon.
Und man sieht es der Katze an, wenn es denen schlecht geht.
Die verstecken sich dann.
Und die ist halt komplett schon rumgewankt.
Und als sie an mir vorbei gelaufen ist.
Und quasi mit dem Kopf gegen die Heizung gerannt ist.
Vor lauter rumwanken.
Und die wollte sie auch nicht mal angreifen lassen.
Da hat man gemerkt, der tut irgendwas weh.
Der geht schlecht.
Und ich gehe mal davon aus, dass ich die Nacht wahrscheinlich auch so nicht überlebt hätte.
Ja, und jetzt habe ich keine Katze mehr.
Jetzt muss ich mal gucken, wann ich mir eine Katze hol wieder.
Wahrscheinlich nächstes Jahr.
Ich habe Hunger.
Fällt mir gerade irgendwie so ein.
Ich weiß auch nicht, wie ich da jetzt drauf komme.
Komplett anderes Thema.
Aber jetzt wollte ich gerade sagen.
Patrick, die unangenehmen Teepie jetzt mal außen vor.
Weil ich habe auch kein Bock mehr, als jedes Mal Gedanken drüber zu machen.
Ähm, wir sind stehen geblieben.
Genau, wir wollten uns dem Raspberry beibringen, dass der Codes lernt.
Hier, da passt doch.
To record a custom remote register a remote device.
Blabla.
Lirk stopp.
Ja, machen wir.
Immer.
Immer Lirk stopp.
I are record.
Okay.
Damit kann man jetzt was aufnehmen, oder was?
Habe ich noch nie verwendet.
Follow instruction prompted by command.
Warum ich den Eufy genommen habe?
Weil es den für 150 Euro bei Amazon gab.
Eigentlich wollte ich gar keinen Staubsauger-Roboter.
Aber ich habe mir gedacht, ey, für 150 Euro kannst du nichts kaputt machen.
Was sagst du, Me-Robot?
Ich habe mich damit null bestärkt.
Oh.
Xiaomi.
Xiaomi oder wie man sich genau spricht.
Ähm, warum ist das auf einmal so teuer?
Der kostet doppelt im Endeffekt, ja.
Und ich glaube, der ist wahrscheinlich auch über Hersteller-App oder sowas.
Das Schöne am Eufy ist ja wirklich, der braucht keine App.
Der braucht kein WLAN, keine Hersteller-Cloud oder sonst was in der Richtung.
Der geht einfach mit der Fernbedienung, wo man die Tastendrücke simulieren kann.
Das finde ich eigentlich ganz gut.
Ja gut, der Eufy fährt halt random durch die Wohnung.
Das ist nicht so toll, aber man...
Im Prinzip, ne, wenn ich den, was weiß ich, wenn ich den jeden Tag da mal für zwei Stunden
rumfahren lasse, dann ist die Wohnung auch so sauber.
Kopierst du die Kommandos mit Steuerung C, Steuerung V?
Ne, die Kommandos kopierst du in der Konsole, weil Steuerung C ist abbrechen.
Die befehlt die, ähm, Kommandos kopierst du entweder mit Steuerung Shift V
oder mit mittlerer Maustaste.
Und je nachdem, wo ich meine Hand gerade habe, ob Tastatur oder Maus
oder wie mache ich mittlere Maustaste oder Steuerung Shift V.
Ja, und wie gesagt, hauptsächlich habe ich den Eufy eigentlich genommen,
weil er 150 Euro, ein paar Mal zu dem Angebot war.
Normal kostet er 190, habe ich gesagt, Scheiß drauf, mach mal.
Auch rein.
Okay, wir versuchen mal, was zu recorden.
Hä?
Lirk, haben wir doch gestoppt.
Warum geht denn das nicht?
RIP.
Aber das andere geht, ne?
Warum geht das nicht?
Warum geht denn das nicht?
Ich kann, das hier geht doch auch.
Warum geht das hier nicht?
Check mal, welche Permissions die Log Datei hat.
Die gibt es überhaupt.
Ah, Moment.
Warum will der, ich bin jetzt der falsche User.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen, dass das Route auch können soll.
Dürfte.
Kann das sein, dass das so ein komischer Befehl ist,
den man nicht als Route ausführen darf?
Aus Gründen, wie auch immer.
Ja.
Alter, ist das bescheuert.
Man muss das als normaler User ausführen.
Okay, meinetwegen.
Also, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla.
Bla, bla, bla.
Return to continue.
Light.
Okay.
Enter name for remote.
Euphi.
Treiben wir mal groß.
It is very important that you, also wir sollen Knöpfe drücken.
Random Knöpfe.
What the fuck?
Was?
Okay.
Es ist wichtig, dass man ganz viele Knöpfe random drückt.
Und alle Knöpfe ungefähr eine Minute hält.
Und dann gibt es irgendwelche Dots auf der... was?
Ja.
Ich dachte immer, Route ist allmächtig.
Ja, Route darf in der Regel auch alles.
Wenn das Programm allerdings so programmiert ist,
dass es unter Route nicht laufen will, kann ja auch uns Route nichts machen.
So, ich muss mal kurz aufstehen und den Euphi ausschalten.
Weil wenn ich jetzt wild auf der Fernbedienung rumdrücke,
dann fährt er hier rum.
Das will ich nicht.
Ich schalte mal kurz aus dem Ding.
Wo ist der Knopf?
Da.
Okay.
Er müsste aus sein.
Warte, soll ich guck mal?
Ja, er macht nichts mehr.
Er macht nichts mehr.
Okay.
Dann dreh ich jetzt mal diesen komischen Empfänger zu mir hin
und mach das, was der Typ hier beschrieben hat.
Ich drücke einfach ganz wild random auf der...
Saugt der Roboter durch den Boden.
Das ist schon wieder so ein dummes Comment, das lustig ist.
Katzenhaare saugt er vor allem.
Den Zukunft hab ich mal wieder.
Okay, ich drücke jetzt random Knöpfe, was da steht.
So, random Knöpfe.
Und immer eine Sekunde downhalten.
Alter Euphi, was machst du für Geräusche?
Der piepst.
Der soll nicht piepsten.
Ich habe nur ausgeschaltet.
Ah, okay.
Was...
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was der da jetzt macht, aber okay.
Please enter the name for the next button.
Home.
Da fährt er nämlich zurück zur Basis.
What?
Please...
Home is not in namespace.
Was so geil ist ein namespace in dem Fall?
Muss man vielleicht sowas hier machen?
Euphi, home?
Hey, was möcht ihr mir da mit der Meldung sagen?
Is not in namespace.
Euphi, home?
Habt ihr eine Idee?
Habt ihr eine Idee, was er für Schmerzen hat überhaupt?
Namespace, home.
Ja, also manche Leute, die Sachen programmieren,
sollten sich mal überlegen, wie das Leuten geht,
die nicht das selbst programmiert haben.
Weil ich mein, was weiß ich, was der Typ von mir will?
Der Button muss existieren, so wie bei einem Makro,
der es so programmiert.
Der sagt doch, ich soll den Name eintippen für den nächsten Button.
Das heißt, ich kann jetzt, ich kann jetzt einen Name vergeben.
Probier mal back.
Nee.
Und außerdem nimmt er das nicht.
Eck, sagt er.
Wisst ihr was, wir machen das jetzt, was der Typ hier hinschreibt.
Disable namespaces.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was es macht, aber wir machen das jetzt.
Löschen, cache, löschen, löschen, löschen.
Gut, nochmal.
Disable namespace.
Continue.
Jetzt checkt er wieder irgendwelche Lites.
Enter remote.
Ja, ok, nochmal Knopfdrückaktion.
Ja klar, muss.
Der Olfi macht wieder Geräusche.
Ja, machen wir.
Ok, please enter name for the next button, home.
Ah, now hold home button.
Aha, ähm, wie nennen wir den Startbutton?
Start, hä?
Einfach Start.
Nee, ich nenne ihn auto, weil das steht auch auf der Family
und da weiß ich, was das für eine Funktion ist.
Now hold down button auto.
Ok.
Ok, ähm, enter finish recording.
Check for toggle bit, was ist das für eine Bedienerführung,
für eine Benutzerführung wieder?
Ok, was sollen wir jetzt machen?
Please press, äh, was, ich soll irgendwelche Knöpfe
so schnell wie es geht drücken.
Same button and don't hold down.
Ok, ich soll jetzt einfach ein Knopf so schnell drücken
wie es irgendwie geht.
Ok, machen wir jetzt mal hier.
Äh, ok.
Das ging jetzt aber schnell.
Auch gut, mal gucken.
So, mal gucken, ob das jetzt funktioniert.
Was haben wir jetzt? Hat er hier eine Datei generiert?
Eine euphilircdconf.
Die muss ich jetzt garantiert irgendwie
in das Verzeichnis von lirc kopieren.
Lirc, lircdconfd, ja, das klingt auch gut.
Read me.
Files in this directory are distributed...
Ich schieb das da jetzt einfach rein.
Home, pie, euphilircdconf.
So.
Und jetzt? Wie geht's jetzt weiter?
Ok, der kopiert die Konfig um drüber.
Das machen wir nicht.
You can test if...
Ok, lirc muss erst mal gestartet werden wieder.
Er sendt, die weiß... Ok, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt,
ob der Scheiß funktioniert.
Ich muss den euphil wieder einschalten.
So, ich teste das jetzt mal mit der...
Ich teste das jetzt mal mit der normalen Fernbedienung,
ob er wieder geht.
Er macht nichts.
Er geht gerade nicht.
Warum geht er nicht?
Moment, ich mach ihn nochmal aus und nochmal an.
Er fährt los.
Ja, fahr zurück.
Schön brav, zurückfahren.
Ja, da, richtige Richtung.
Richtige Richtung.
Ja, fein andocken.
Ok, er ist wieder angedockt.
Er funktioniert.
Ok, ähm...
Hast du das Hardware-Rad-Projekt schon fertig?
Na, fertig nicht wirklich.
Wir haben es jetzt getestet bei denen.
Wenn es funktioniert, gibt es übrigens ein lustiges Video dazu.
Kann ich euch gerade mal zeigen.
Hardware-Rad-Twitter.
Ähm...
Ich mach das.
Äh, Twitter kann ich auf Twitter weglassen, ey.
Hier.
Das ist eigentlich ganz lustig.
Ähm, ich mach mal kurz Sound an.
Wir können uns das einfach auch hier im Windows angucken.
Sound, Sound.
Ich hoffe man hört's.
Achtung.
Max.
Ein kleines Problem mit deinem...
...Aktivator...
...spielt unten Transpress-Energy-to-Exit.
Wenn ich jetzt irgendeinen Knopf drücke, zum Beispiel den da...
...wie der PC aus.
Sollte gehoben werden.
Das ist so dumm, dass es irgendwie lustig ist.
Das ist so bescheuert.
Ich hab erst gedacht, als er das geschickt hat,
irgendwie wäre was kaputt.
Dabei war es einfach nur ganz hart und Chibate.
Okay.
Ähm.
Aber das funktioniert.
Das funktioniert.
Wir bauen da noch ein paar Sachen ein.
Wir können auch wieder Onstream machen.
Ich hab ein paar Sachen gefunden, die noch praktisch werden.
Aber ich find's halt nice.
Dass man da mal wirklich, ähm...
...dass man auch wirklich mal Leuten mit was helfen kann.
Mit was Selbstgebasteltem.
Ähm, also...
Quasi jemand, der was braucht.
Und man kann's machen.
Und dann gar keinen großen Akt macht.
Sondern sich einfach denkt, ey, lass mal basteln.
Vor allem, ich hab's ja hauptsächlich...
...ich hab's ja hauptsächlich auch gemacht, dass ich streamen kann.
Wie man das Ganze programmiert.
Und...
...es ist natürlich jetzt doppelt nice, dass es auch noch gut funktioniert.
Und jetzt können sie quasi ihre Windows-PCs damit aktivieren.
Und Windows-Keys verwalten.
Und sowas in der Richtung.
Ihr habt's wahrscheinlich im Stream gesehen.
Wer es nicht gesehen hat, kann, glaube ich...
...was ist das Kommando?
Ausrufezeichen?
HW-Tool?
HW-Rad? Hardware-Rad? Ich weiß es gar nicht.
Gibt's ein Kommando zu, ähm...
...wo ich erkläre, was wir da programmiert haben...
...und was das Programm macht.
Okay.
Äh, jetzt versuchen wir mal dem Eufy was zu...
...HR-Tool was.
Siehste, ihr kennt meine eigenen Kommandos besser als ich.
Äh...
ER-Send.
Also, Eufy.
Auto.
Geht nicht.
Ach so, ich sollte vielleicht mal...
...den Raspberry in die Richtung vom Eufy drehen, ha?
Wäre nicht schlecht.
Der muss den ja auch sehen können.
Achtung.
Ha! Er fährt los!
Leute! Okay.
Um!
Und er fährt zurück.
Grasser Scheiß! Poggers!
Wo fährt er denn lang?
Oh! Oh mein Gott!
Besser als Battlefield.
Achtung, volle Immersion, Leute.
Passt mal auf.
Headset abziehen.
Achtung, Headset abziehen.
Headset ist zu kurz.
Voller Eufy-Immersion.
Achtung.
So.
Und jetzt?
Jetzt fährt er wieder heim.
Grasser Scheiß, ha?
Oh!
Oh mein Gott!
So, wir starten jetzt einen Container mit Ubuntu 18.04 drinnen und dort installieren
wir uns den Home Assistant.
Was sagt ihr übrigens mal dazu?
Zu meiner nice Systemstatusleiste hier oben, die ist doch echt cool, oder?
Vor allem mit dem Auslastungs Emoji dran und das ist doch sehr nice.
Manjaro, weil ich mich mag Manjaro.
Ich wüsste jetzt nicht, was ein eigenes Arch Linux für Vorteile hätte, ich meine,
das ist eine Manjaro-Minimalinstallation, außer dass es einen die Installation abnimmt
und ein bisschen einfacher macht, ist da eigentlich alles custom.
Serious Max, das ist eine mega geile Idee, das ist eine übertrieben geile Idee, Twitch
Chat Cleans Apartment, das muss ich mir ausschreiben.
Ohne Scheiß, das ist eine richtig geile Idee, da kann der Twitch Chat dann quasi den Roboter
steuern.
Das ist eine übelst geile Idee und selbst wenn wir es nicht machen, wir könnten das
mal programmieren wenigstens, da würde ich dann quasi eine Kamera hinstellen ins Wohnzimmer
und den Roboter reinstellen und der Chat kann dann quasi steuern.
Am besten mit Kamera-Pof, noch besser, wobei Kamera-Pof ist gar nicht so einfach, ich könnte
zwar eine Raspberry mit Kamera auf den Eufy drauf stellen, die Sache ist bloß, die Kamera
muss irgendwie mit Strom versorgt werden und der Eufy hat keinen USB-Stecker, das heißt,
ich kriege nicht so ohne weiteres aus dem Eufy Akku Strom raus, außerdem wird es wahrscheinlich
auch die Laufzeit ein bisschen beeinträchtigen.
Akku-Pack, das hält nicht lange mit einem Raspberry, das hält einen Tag, wenn es hochkommt,
wenn es hochkommt einen Tag und mit Kamera dran wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal einen Tag,
mit Kamera dran wahrscheinlich irgendwie einen halben Tag oder so.
Die Raspberries sind zwar relativ stromsparend, allerdings so stromsparend, nur auch wieder
nicht, dass die lange an der Powerbank laufen.
Man müsste es irgendwie so machen, dass dann quasi, wenn der Eufy dockt, die Powerbank
mit auflädt, das müsste man irgendwie basteln.
Was ist eigentlich deine Meinung zum Black Friday, das ist komplett überflüssig, es
gibt ein paar gute Angebote, aber zum größten Teil ist es eigentlich nur, wir machen auf
super Aktionen und nix dahinter, weil, guckt euch mal die Preise bei Amazon an, 90% der
Sachen bei Amazon sind gar nicht wirklich billiger, da guckst du mal Geilzahls und es
sind vielleicht 2-3 Euro Unterschied.
Es gibt ab und zu wieder richtig gute Aktionen, wie die mit dem Eufy jetzt, allerdings die
gibt es ja über auch.
Den Eufy auf, ich gehe mal davon aus, dass das nicht so ohne weiteres funktioniert, selbst
wenn ich das machen würde, ich gehe mal davon aus, dass die Spannung überhaupt nicht stimmt
vom Eufy, ich glaube das kannst du vergessen.
Hätte der Eufy einen USB Anschluss, würde das ganze anders aussehen.
Ok, wir wollten Home Assistant installieren, LXC, EXAC, BASH, so jetzt sind wir in unserem
Home Assistant Container drinne und jetzt machen wir hier mal die Installation, das ist relativ
simpel, einfach BAM, ach nee, UPDATE, die Musik können wir wieder anmachen, nicht wundern
dass es jetzt so schnell ist, wir sind nicht mehr auf dem Raspberry, wir sind in meiner
VM, wir haben eine Container für Home Assistant in meiner VM gestartet.
Das schöne an Containern an der Geschichte, also in der Situation ist jetzt einfach, wenn
ich fertig testen bin, schmeiße ich es einfach wieder weg und mein System wird nicht voll
gemüllt, mit Zeugs was ich vergesse zu löschen, so, jetzt können wir Home Assistant installieren
klar.
Gibt es eigentlich eine Staubsauger Modding Community, ich könnte wetten sowas gibt es,
also es gibt auf GitHub ein paar Projekte, auch für den Eufy habe ich schon gesehen,
es hat mich ja überhaupt erst auf die Idee gebracht sowas selbst zu basteln.
Jetzt einfach starten, der Hass wird gestartet, wenn das der Fabian hört, wenn der Hass gestartet
wird, dann erstmal installieren, das ist jetzt auch wieder so eine Abkürzung von Home Assistant,
die halt in deutsch wieder doof klingt, das ist genauso wie der Hoster Wix.com, das klingt
auf deutsch so hängen geblieben Alter, ich habe meine Webseite bei Wix.com, wie es das
anhörte und was ist dein Hoster, Wix.com ist mein Hoster, ich hoste meine Webseite auf
Wix.com, das ist halt, manche Sachen sind halt in unterschiedlichen Sprachen dumm und
bei manchen gibt es das Wort nicht, so starten, unable to find configuration, creating default
configuration, ja go go, Error, ganz viele Errors, da darf man sich übrigens nichts draus
machen, Home Assistant spamt am Anfang immer Errors rum und nachdem man es einmal gestartet
hat, ist es wieder gut.
Haha, wie kenne ich die Wärmung der Eichschlau.
So, alles jetzt fertig rumgespackt hier, wir brechen das mal ab, starten wir nochmal neu,
ah jetzt funktioniert es, was auch immer, der für schmerzen hat, ok, wir müssen uns
noch die IP raussuchen, wartet mal, sind wir deswegen in TMAX, jetzt ist TMAX SEPTION
angesagt, also wir brauchen unsere IP von dem Container, den da, so neues Tab, oben starten
wir Home Assistant, unten gucken wir, ob der Port auf ist, ob es fertig gestartet ist,
sollte Port 8123 sein, hältst du das ganze Smart Home unintelligente Kühlschränke und
so weiter für sinnvoll, äh intelligente Kühlschränke, da hatten wir es das letzte Mal, als wir uns
die Amazon Deals angeguckt haben, intelligente Kühlschränke sind leider aktuell nicht wirklich
intelligent, ist eigentlich komplett überflüssig, Smart Home selbst gebaut ist das beste, was
man machen kann, dafür basteln wir ja das heute im Prinzip auch, ok, Home Assistant
ist wahr, gestartet, ne, ist immer noch gestartet, ok, Username, Admin, Passwort 123456, Login,
Admin 123456, so, das ist die Standard Installation von Home Assistant, man sieht, da ist nichts
drinne, es hält sich wirklich ganz stark in Grenzen, was da drin ist, es ist ein Beispiel
Sensor angelegt und zwar für, äh, ja Sonne oder, äh, sprich Nacht oder Tag und irgendwie
ein Wettersymbol, das ist standardmäßig drinne, mehr nicht, so und hier kann man natürlich
dann sein ganzes Smart Home Gedöns einrichten, Home Assistant hat, ähm, Komponenz, Home
Assistant hat irgendwie, ja guck mal, 1220 verschiedene Komponenten, die so ziemlich alles
unterstützt, was es irgendwie gibt, ja, sogar eine Komponente für die Bahn, so und wir
brauchen jetzt wahrscheinlich, ich bin mir jetzt nicht ganz sicher, wie wir das gescheit
machen, wir müssen jetzt einen neuen Schalter anlegen, einen Schalter für Eufy on off und
da bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher, wie man das macht, weil, guck mal, wie man das am
besten, am besten, äh, regeln, also normalerweise würde ich so machen, also für, für meinen,
für mein normales Setup würde ich das, ähm, nicht so machen wie hier und zwar, also für
mein normales Home Assistant Setup würde ich irgendwie schauen, dass ich meine Nachrichten
per MQTT verschicke, das ist so ein Message Bus, wo man dann quasi, ähm, bestimmte Sachen
subscriben kann und dann quasi sowas wie Standardinformationen kriegt, darüber würde ich das eigentlich normalerweise
nicht steuern, aber wir machen es jetzt mal relativ einfach, wir versuchen einfach einen
Shell Command in, in Home Assistant einzubauen und dass wir dann am Ende hier unseren Eufy
drin haben und einen Knopf für Start Stop, was kann die Bahn Komponente, die Bahn Komponente
kann, ähm, Verbindungen raussuchen und dir Verspätung anzeigen und dann kannst du damit
mit Automatisierung drauf reagieren, also du kannst dann sagen, wenn die Bahn Komponente
eine Verspätung größer 5 Minuten meldet, dann mache das Licht im Flur auf Orange, wenn
die Verspätung größer als 10 Minuten ist, dann mache das Flur im Licht, äh, äh, äh,
mache das Licht im Flur Rot, sowas in der Richtung kannst du da machen. Ja und man
kann glaube ich noch Intervalleinstellen, wie oft er bei der Bahn abfragt, ich glaube Standards
in 5 Minuten oder irgendwie so. So, wie machen wir das jetzt richtig? Also, mal kurz checken,
wie das Ganze funktioniert. So, Ben. Alles für immer Rot, genau. So, jetzt müssen wir
mal gucken, wo unsere Home Assistant Config steckt, wahrscheinlich wir im Home Assistant Configuration,
genau. So, und man sieht, die Home Assistant Config ist auch relativ simpel, ja, das ist
alles so komisches Jammen geschmubbelt und da probieren wir jetzt mal einen Switch einzufügen,
einen Command Line Switch und dann gucken wir mal, ob das im Web Interface erscheint.
Wow, kannst du das mal ordentlich formatieren? Äh, ach fuck, wie war das nochmal? Set, Paste
war das, genau. So, jetzt sieht es besser aus. Switch, Platform, Kitchen Light, Euphi, Staubsauger,
Switch Command, On, Off, Examples, Switches. Ah, man kann, man kann den Commando, das Commando
direkt reinschreiben. Echo 1, ich probiere jetzt einfach mal aus, ob der Switch im Web
Interface jetzt funktioniert. Echo 2 und jetzt starten wir das Ganze nochmal. Gehen wir mal
ins Web Interface, gucken, ob das so passt. Da ist er, Switch Euphi Staubsauger. Der macht
jetzt natürlich noch nichts, weil, ähm, ich habe ja nur Echo 1 und 2 reingeschrieben
und nicht den eigentlichen Befehl. So, also so wird es dann im Web Interface aussehen.
So, und, also, wie gesagt, ich kann euch mein Home Assistant Panel nicht zeigen, da sind
zu viele private Sachen drinne. Allerdings, ähm, ich habe schon, ich habe mehrere Tabs.
Ich habe auch die neue Oberfläche mittlerweile, die haben, ähm, die haben eine neue Oberfläche,
die sieht ein bisschen, die sieht ein bisschen schicker aus, wenn man sich das hier anguckt
als die alte. Aber, wenn euch Home Assistant interessiert, müsst ihr euch das mal in Ruhe
angucken. Ähm, ich habe halt hier noch verschiedene Tabs oben für verschiedene Räume und verschiedene
Dinge und halt quasi jedes Tab auch noch voll mit Gedöns. Also, da ist dann schon noch
ein bisschen mehr, als jetzt nur eins, nur ein Switch, ne? So, ähm, so, und jetzt hat
man einen Switch für den Staubsauger. Kann dann quasi sagen, an, aus, was er jetzt ja
aktuell nicht macht, weil wir noch kein Command haben. Und jetzt versuchen wir mal, jetzt
versuchen wir mal dem Ding beizubringen. Und wir versuchen erstmal von hier manuell das
Ganze zu schicken. Okay. Also, wir müssen jetzt, also, die Log, von der Logik her, wir
müssen jetzt von unserem, von unserem, äh, von unserer Smart Homes, von unserem Smart
Homes, Smart Home Server, müssen wir uns auf den Raspberry verbinden und den Raspberry
den, äh, Infrarotbefehl zum Losfahren für den Euphi schicken lassen. Das ist der Befehl,
das heißt SSH. Normalerweise hätte der Raspberry bei mir auch einen Namen im DNS, hat er jetzt
nicht, ist ja nur zum, zum Testen. So. Pi, Ads, bla, bla, bla, E, Ascent, Auto. Raspberry.
Er fährt los. Habt ihr das gehört? Er fährt los. Euphi fahrt zurück. Zurückfahren. Fahrt
zur Station. Fahrt zur Station. Fahrt zur Station. Ja, so ist brav. Fein. Feiner Euphi.
So fein. Jetzt fängt man schon an mit dem, mit seinem Staubsauger zu reden. Okay. Also,
das ist das Kommando. Jetzt müssen wir noch mal gucken, dass wir uns da auch passwortlos
einloggen können. Dazu generieren wir erstmal ein paar SSH Keys. Muss. Ohne SSH Keys, nicht
einloggen. Nicht, äh, kann man sich nicht einloggen. Jetzt sagen wir SSH. Copy ID.
Dahin. Und jetzt können wir uns passwortlos einloggen. Richtig. So. Und von der Idee her
muss ich jetzt eigentlich nur das da in die Home Assistant Config eintragen. Als Command.
On Command. Off Command is Home. Und dann hab ich nen Button, mit dem ich mein Euphi starten
und stoppen kann. Und ihn auch in Automatisierung verwenden kann. Könnte. Das ist wie gesagt
nur ne Test Home Assistant Instanz. Stoppen wir das Ganze und starten es noch mal. Dismiss.
So Leute, ich lass euch noch mal mithören. Wenn wir jetzt den Knopf im Webinterface drücken.
Fährt er los, hör das? Wenn ich jetzt auf ausdrücke, fährt er zur Station zurück.
Wenn er sie findet. Er findet sie grad nicht. Doch, jetzt hat er sie gefunden. Und das ist
alles. Ist übelst nice. Wie gesagt, ich würde euch gern mal der... Achso, ähm, soll ich
euch mal die Bahn Komponente noch zeigen? Weil es ja ein paar Leute interessiert hat
vorhin. Ich kann euch die Bahn Komponente noch mal zeigen. Hier sieht man jetzt auch wieder
wie wichtig TMAX ist. Ähm, wir müssen erst noch mal ausschalten, dass immer dieses komische
Pop-Up kommt. Das ging doch hier irgendwie. Konnte man noch irgendwo einschalten? Egal.
Sensor. Set. Paste. Plattform Deutsche Bahn. Von wo nach wo fahren wir denn jetzt mal?
Wir fahren von Frankfurt nach Dresden. Wir fahren zum Friseur. Wir fahren zum Fahrrad.
Und jetzt sagen wir dem Ding noch, ähm, only direct. Jetzt sagen wir dem Ding noch only
direct true. Und ich glaube das war's im Großen und Ganzen. Starten wir neu. Hört sich sicher.
Jammel ist sehr empfindlich was Einrückung angeht. Da muss man ein bisschen aufpassen.
So. Äh, der Bahn Sensor geht nicht. Was hab ich jetzt vergessen? Äh, hab ich jetzt
irgendwas vergessen? Ähm, tja. Was oben wird's angezeigt? Ach, tatsächlich. Da wird's
angezeigt. Da ist es doch. Ich hab's nicht gesehen. Ja, ich dachte irgendwie das kommt
hier, aber es ist Blödsinn. In meinem Interface zeigt er hier was an. Ähm, was ich gebastelt
hab mit dem, mit, äh, mit dem neuen Frontend. Aber standardmäßig ist das ja einfach nur
ein Sensor und wird hier oben angezeigt. Genau. Nächste Verbindung von Frankfurt nach Dresden
ist um 7.16. Ernsthaft? Ja. Ach nee. Moment. Zeitzone sollten wir vielleicht noch ändern.
Das ist, äh, Ami-Zeit. Time. Time. Äh. Das liegt an meinem Frontend, weil mein Browser
oft Englisch ist. Okay, also die nächste Verbindung nach Dresden wäre dann um 19.16
von Frankfurt nach Dresden aus und ist nicht delayed, was auch, äh, das Ding ist ja wahrscheinlich
noch nicht mal losgefahren. Richtig. Nehmen wir mal eine andere Verbindung. Ja, genau,
das ist das, das ist das Bahnmodul. So, und das sind im Prinzip die ganzen, ähm, Eigenschaften,
auf die man zugreifen kann. Wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel ein Licht hätte oder, äh, sagen
wir mal den Euphi, ja, genau, wir haben jetzt den Euphi, dann könnte ich jetzt sagen, in,
in, äh, Automatisierung könnte ich jetzt einrichten, dass wenn von der Bahnkomponente,
ähm, Delay Arrival, was auch immer, oder Delay größer 5 ist, dann geht der Euphi an,
was ne total bescheuerde Automatisierung ist, weil warum sollte ich mein Staubsauger anschalten
wollen, wenn die Bahn 5 Minuten später ist. Aber jetzt, jetzt nur mal als Beispiel, ja,
das könnte ich jetzt machen. Und ich hab, ich hab gesehen, sie haben wohl irgendwie
auch nen, nen Editor irgendwie jetzt, wo man das machen kann. Hab ich noch nie verwendet,
das Ding. Genau, da kann man irgendwie sagen, State, ähm, Frankfurt, Dresden. Hab ich
noch nie verwendet, das Ding. Keine Ahnung, wie das funktioniert.
Keine Ahnung, wie man das mit diesem Editor macht. Weiß es nicht. Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Ich hab das noch nie über diesen komischen, über das Webfrontend gemacht. State. Ich
müsste da noch eigentlich sowas anzeigen wie Delay. Keine Ahnung, wie das im Webfrontend
funktioniert. Ich weiß, keine Ahnung. Das ist, ja, ich, ich finde es für mich ist das
viel komplizierter, quasi im Webfrontend ne Automatisierung zusammen zu klicken als
entweder hier im Jammel zu basteln oder, also du hast in Home Assistant hast du drei verschiedene
Möglichkeiten, was du machen kannst. Das kann dir an der Stelle mal zeigen. Du kannst
einmal Automatisierung, vier, vier Möglichkeiten, wenn du Automatisierung machen willst. Du
hast einmal dieses komische, diesen komischen Editor hier, den ich jetzt schon mal gar nicht
checke ehrlich gesagt. Dann kannst du, dann kannst du hier in Jammel Automatisierung machen.
Auto, automation, ich kann jetzt nicht schreiben das Wort. Automation, ja. Ähm, kannst du
in Jammel schreiben. Sieht dann irgendwie so aus. Ja, das ist der Automation, alias Trigger,
wenn die Sonne ne Stunde vor dem Untergehen ist, dann Trigger das und das. So, dann gibt
es als nächstes die Möglichkeiten, die finde ich eigentlich am besten. Ähm, den Abdemen,
den finde ich am besten, da kannst du nämlich die ganze Logik in Python selbst programmieren.
Und die Logik, wie gesagt, die Logik ist ja meistens nicht sonderlich kompliziert für
so ne Automatisierung. So nach dem Motto, wenn Bahn delayed größer fünf, dann Licht auf
orange. Die Logik ist meistens relativ einfach und ich bastel die Dinger in, dann die Logik
gerne in Python selbst. Das ist nicht schwierig und ich kann Logik besser in Programmiersprachen
ausdrücken als in Jammel oder in nem Web Editor. Das ist aber jedem, jeder sein eigenes Geschmack.
So, und was dann noch ganz cool ist, für Leute, die gerne klicken, ist das hier. Das ist
richtig cool. Das ist ein Malprogramm für Heimautomatisierungen. Es ist kein Malprogramm
für Heimautomatisierungen, es ist eigentlich was, wo du halt verschiedene Komponenten zusammenstecken
kannst, aber mit Node-RED, das können wir theoretisch auch mal angucken, kannst du ähm,
quasi Automatisierung selbst zusammenstöpseln. Das ist dann eigentlich ganz cool. Das können
wir eigentlich mal machen. Ich hab das noch nie selbst installiert. Ähm, das können
wir mal ausprobieren. How to. Das dürfte eigentlich für Leute, die keinen Bock haben,
in Jammel die Automatisierung zu machen, die beste Variante sein, die es aktuell so gibt.
Ähm, mach so ein Video zu deinem Smart Home-Gedöns vielleicht mal irgendwann. Was steuerst du
denn alles für Geräte über ein Smart Home? Ähm, ähm, Geräte steuern? So richtig steuern
eigentlich? Eigentlich jetzt nur den Staubsauger, wenn man mal so will. Also mal, abgesehen
von solchen Dingen wie Lichter und sowas, ja, das ist ja so Standardzeug. Aber so irgendwelche
Geräte wirklich steuern? Eigentlich nicht. Ich mein, ich hab jede Menge Sensoren, aber
die liefern ja Daten und, äh, steuern nix. Also wirklich steuern tu ich wenig über mein
Smart Home. Jetzt eigentlich nur den Staubsauger hier. Äh, ich steuer paar Lampen. Mir geht's
hauptsächlich darum, zum Anzeigen von Informationen, so nach dem Motto, ich hab vergessen das Fenster
zuzumachen. Oder die Heizung im Keller hat einen Fehler oder sowas in der Richtung. Oder,
ähm, oder, keine Ahnung, ich bin zwei Kilometer von zu Hause entfernt und auf dem Weg heim,
dann geht die Klimaanlage im Sommer an und sowas. Ja gut, das ist auch steuern im Prinzip.
Ja, ja, genau. Ähm, das ist im Prinzip auch steuern. Aber ich hab jetzt irgendwie an größere
Geräte gedacht gerade mit Steuern. Ja, Klimaanlage, Lichter werden gesteuert. Was wird noch gesteuert?
Ähm, der Staubsauger jetzt hier demnächst. Ähm, paar Tablets, so von wegen Bildschirm
an, Bildschirm aus. Dann hab ich auf dem Fernseher noch nen Alarm, wenn die Tür aufgemacht
wird. So Zeug, ja. Aber hauptsächlich gehts mir eigentlich bei der Smart-Home-Geschichte
eher um Informationen anzeigen. So wie, ich geh aus der Tür und hab vergessen im Bad
das Fenster zuzumachen. Oder ich möchte wissen, ob im Briefkasten was ist. Oder ich will
ne Statusübersicht, ob ich heute Pakete krieg. Oder sowas in der Richtung. Ja, das, das
ist eigentlich hauptsächlich, hauptsächlich eher Informationen anzeigen, steuern weniger
eigentlich. Gibt's ja auch nicht viel zu steuern, ja. Neben der Klimaanlage und ein paar Lichtern.
Ja. So, was wollten wir jetzt noch machen? Ich wollte Note Red installieren, ja. Äh.
Was sind das für ne komische Anleitung, äh. Da gab's bestimmt ein ganz gutes Total.
Wie machst du das mit dem Brief, ja das funktioniert nicht so, nicht so richtig gut. Da ist einfach
nen Fenstersensor drinne, nen öffnen geschlossenen Sensor ist da drinne. Am, am Einwurf, das
funktioniert aber nicht so richtig gut. Weil, weil der Abstand meistens nicht groß genug
ist, wie es auseinander geht. Das ist optimierungsäh, bedürftig. Okay. Ja, das können wir jetzt
noch machen. Äh, gucken wir uns doch mal an, wie man eine Automatisierung schön. Hab ich
Note installiert, ja. Ubuntu. Ubuntu, das hab ich schon lange nicht mehr gemacht. Ähm.
Note. Ja, genau. Die haben nämlich eigene, eigene Repost dafür, das ist ganz gut. Hauptsache
man alles komplett nach Bashpipen. Ah, YOLO. Okay, jetzt haben wir Note drauf. Gibt's da
nicht irgendeinen ordentlichen Guide für, für Home Assistant mit Note Red? Weil das
ist wirklich ganz cool, das wollte ich euch noch mal zeigen für alle die, die es quasi
mit, mit so Hardcore programmieren nicht haben und keinen Bock haben auf diese komische YAML
Config. Welche Türen, Fenstersensoren hast du, die, äh, so billige von AliExpress, weil
die plus neun Dollar gekostet haben, ähm, kann ich dir zeigen. Da muss man aber, muss
man aber auf ne Aktion warten. Äh, Z-Wave, Window, Sensor. Die da. Die da. Das ist aber
immer noch relativ teuer. Ich hab die mal für neun Dollar oder so das Stück gekriegt
als, als Aktion war. Da hab ich den riesen Pack bestellt. Ja, das ist, das ist zu teuer
gerade. Da kannst du's auch hier fast kaufen für den Preis. Muss man, muss man abwarten,
bis es wieder günstige Varianten von gibt. Wenn man AliExpress bestellt, ist immer so
ne Sache, man, man darf nicht direkt bestellen, muss manchmal ein bisschen abwarten. Aber
die hab ich. Äh, was? Meinung zu was? Also zu Fenstersensor, ja, wie gesagt, die, die
hab ich hier. Jetzt gibt's das vielleicht als, ähm, als Paket schon. Ne. Ahja, da gibt's
doch ein Video, wie der Typ das macht. Zeig dir auch, wie man's installiert. Ne. Und im
Prinzip ist wahrscheinlich NPM installen, ne. Was? Warum ist das so kompliziert?
Äh, warum ist denn schon die Musik aus? Man kann doch bestimmt einfach machen. Install,
alright. Ja, geht doch. Ha, warum auch immer die das nicht einfach auf ihre Installseite
schreiben, äh. Danach installieren wir die Home Assistant Komponente. Oh, was? Oh, du
Scheiße, was geht jetzt ab? Was hat der jetzt für Schmerzen? Ich will einfach nur was installieren.
Warum will er länger kompilieren und tun und machen, äh? What the fuck? Okay, hat er
das jetzt installiert? Alright. Hat er nicht installiert, oder? Ai, ai, ai, ai, ai. Was
ist denn halt zu kompliziert? Node, Modules. Warum ist das immer, warum ist das ganze JavaScript-Zeug
so wieder so übelst kompliziert? Node Red Pie? What the fuck? Pie? Okay. 1-1-8-0. Ne.
1-8-8-0. Okay, funktioniert. Genau, und da kann man sich jetzt eine Automatisierung mit
zusammenklicken. Jetzt erleben wir nochmal das Home Assistant Addon. Wie sieht bei dir
aktuell dein Home Server aus? Das ist ein Ubuntu drauf mit, ähm, ne, ne, kein Docker,
mit, ähm, LXD, LXC. Docker ist mir da zu, zu, äh, was nicht, zu nervig im Handling,
ja. Ich mag das eigentlich für so, für solche Fälle, wenn man nicht die einzelne Anwendung
virtualisiert, sondern sich, was geht denn eigentlich ab da? Was hat er denn für Probleme,
ja? Das ist bei, bei Node Red ist, äh, ich weiß nicht, bei VM ist das Zeug immer übelst
kaputt und dann geht es trotzdem, ja. So, und jetzt hat man nämlich hier die ganze Home
Assistant Geschichte drin. Und jetzt kann man zum Beispiel sagen, und ich glaube, das,
das ist für alle Leute cool, die es nicht so mit, so mit Hardcore-Programmiergeschichten
haben. Jetzt kannst du zum Beispiel sagen, ähm, wenn jetzt quasi der State von, irgendwie,
von der Bahn oder so, ich sag, ich benutze das normalerweise nicht, ich kann es irgendwie
sagen, wenn der State von der Bahn, Delay größer fünf Minuten ist, dann, ähm, dann
mach irgendwas, dann, dann schick eine Nachricht an Twitter oder so und danach, keine Ahnung,
danach sagste, ähm, der Eufy soll fahren. So in der Richtung. Also sprich, dann kann
man seine, seine Automatisierung so zusammenklicken. Aber ich verwende das normalerweise nicht,
deswegen kann ich tatsächlich allzu viel sagen, ich weiß auch gar nicht, wie man das hier
ordentlich einrichten kann, um ehrlich zu sein. Wie macht man das dann eigentlich jetzt?
Man muss es ja noch mit seiner Home-Assistant-Config irgendwie verbinden, ne? Wie macht man das
denn jetzt richtig? Man muss doch irgendwie noch bestimmt eine Konfig für das Ding anlegen.
Weil, ich mein, woher, was soll der wissen, wo sonst meine, meine, ah, da, add new server,
mein Home-Assistant-Server war, ähm, acht, eins, zwei, drei, ab die Passwort, hatte ich
glaub ich nicht. Done. Cannot get, okay, ähm, wie schaltet man die API ein? Eigentlich wollte
ich es euch nur kurz zeigen, jetzt atet das schon wieder aus, ey. Ah, einfach API rein
sein. Nein, nein, wir setzen kein Passwort, das ist komplett overrated Passwort. Okay,
jetzt hier einfach API rein. Uah, vim, keine Magic machen. Keine Magic vim, einfach, einfach,
einfach tun, ne, einfach machen. So, und hat er sich jetzt verbunden? Äh, okay.
API Passwort haben wir nicht, add, done. Cannot get, ich hab keine Ahnung, was der für Schmerzen
hat. Ich wollte es euch jetzt eigentlich nur zeigen, weil das ganz cool ist für Leute,
die, ähm, die es nicht so mit programmieren haben, aber ich hab keine Ahnung warum das
jetzt nicht funktioniert. Und, äh, hab auch kein Bock da großartig rumzudebuggen. Es
gibt ein fertiges Addon dafür. Wird dein Aktivator noch weiterentwickelt? Ja, klar. Was hast du
eigentlich für dein CPU im Rechner in 8700K? Moment.
Die gibt's überhaupt nicht, die Ull. Kann es sein, dass das Addon einfach kacke ist?
Das soll es ja gar nicht getten. Oder auch nicht. Entities, immer an Worte. Gut. Man
weiß es nicht genau, warum es nicht funktioniert. Ähm, ich mein, das Ding könnte jetzt nochmal
ordentliche, ich mein, ich hab den Server hinzugefügt, ja. API Passwort haben wir nicht vergeben.
Und der Server ist ja an der Stelle auch, auch da. Also im Prinzip, ah, HTTP Komponent.
Muss man vielleicht so machen? Ok, wartet mal Leute, wir stoppen nochmal. Machen wir
mal hier. Passwort 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6. Beste Passwort. 9, blow it up, 1, 9, 8, 5, 1985.
Ist ein Jahr jünger als ich. Was wird heute gemacht? Eigentlich sind wir schon fertig,
mehr oder weniger. Ja, eigentlich sind wir mehr oder weniger schon fertig. Ich zeig jetzt
gerade noch mein Heimautomatisierungstorch. Ähm, und wollt euch eigentlich zeigen, wie
man das schön machen kann, weil man nicht programmieren will. Aber, der mag nicht.
Ok Leute, keine Ahnung, wie der Scheiß funktioniert. Ähm, es wäre ja ganz, ganz nice gewesen,
ja. Es wäre ganz cool gewesen, hätte das funktioniert. Ich meine, geht es jetzt doch
oder was? Geht es jetzt doch? Nee, wahrscheinlich nicht, oder? Doch, funktioniert doch. Alter,
was ist das? Wer hat dieses komische Frontend? Wer hat dieses Frontend gebastelt? Ja, xhele
ist so, ich programmier das auch lieber. So, und jetzt könnt mal sagen, wenn Sensor Frankfurt
zu Dresden oder, kann man irgendwie noch sagen, Delay oder sowas? Ja, Services. Das ging doch
irgendwie mit Delay. Oh, haha, ich glaube, ich hab's kaputt gemacht. So, mal neu starten.
Ja, also ich finde es auch einfacher zu programmieren, anstatt das hier zu machen. Ja, jetzt haben
wir hier irgendwie Delay, 0 Minuten, ok. Neu starten, immer neu starten. Ah ja, hier,
da ist es doch. So, und jetzt kann man doch hier irgendwie sagen, up der Intervall jede
Sekunde, bam, jetzt haben wir hier mal Debug, dass er was ausgibt und dann gucken wir mal,
ob das Ganze funktioniert. Sollte jetzt hier irgendwas ausgeben. Also, es sollte jetzt
eigentlich was ausgeben, achte ich. Ah ja, hier. So. Geh mal aus. Data. Ja, da ist es
wieder. Data. LastChange, State, Attributes. So, und da kann man sich das jetzt irgendwie
rausholen, Delay, Delay. Kann man nicht vielleicht einfach auch sowas hier sagen? Delay. Ach,
keine Ahnung. Deswegen, deswegen programmier ich das selbst. Ich hab das, aber an sich
ist das eine coole Sache für Leute, die nicht so, also quasi Logik nicht jetzt in der Programmiersprache
basteln wollen, sondern lieber was zum zusammenklicken haben. Da ist das ganz, ganz nett für. Aber
wie gesagt, ich verwende das nicht. Wir probieren das noch mal, ob wir nicht irgendwie rauskriegt,
wie man das machen kann. Wobei man teilweise immer noch ein bisschen, bisschen Logik drin
braucht, ja. Dass man jetzt irgendwie sagen kann, wie sagt man jetzt eigentlich, größer
gleich. Da gibt es auch bestimmt irgendwie ein If oder sowas. If. If. Kann man das If
sagen? Also ich weiß schon, warum ich den Kram nicht verwende normalerweise. Wie kann
man das jetzt sagen? If. Gibt es das nicht auch? If. So. Oder Filter oder sowas. Switch,
Switch. Okay, Switch. Eine Güte. Switch. Ah, und jetzt kann man sagen, wenn größer,
glaube ich, noch mal aus. When payload. Data, Agibirds, Delay. Also, also, also, also, also,
also, also, also. When data add the booters. Delay größer, größer fünf. Dann. Okay,
okay. Okay, jetzt kriegen wir natürlich kein Output, weil das nicht größer als fünf
ist. Jetzt sagen wir mal, wenn es kleiner fünf ist, dann müsste es eigentlich funktionieren.
Dann funktioniert es. Dann kriegen wir die Ausgabe drauf. Das heißt, wenn ich mir sowas
hier mal zusammengebastelt habe, dann könnte ich jetzt hier quasi sagen, wenn mein, wenn
die Bahn verspät, also mache ich hier irgendwie so Bahn. Ich sage es für die Leute, die nicht
selbst die Logik programmieren wollen. Wenn die Bahnverspätung größer fünf Minuten.
Ich weiß, dass es hier kleiner steht, aber es ist ja gerade null. Wenn die Bahnverspätung
größer fünf Minuten ist, dann sagen wir. Wie, wie sage ich denn jetzt? Trigger state.
Wie setze ich denn jetzt was? Ich würde jetzt zum Beispiel den Eufy einschalten, wenn die
Bahn über größer fünf Minuten Verspätung hat. Call Service wahrscheinlich. Oder auch
nicht. Trigger state. Ah ja, hier. Eufy Staubsauger.
Das ist jetzt mal ganz ernsthaft. Einfacher ist das auch nicht wirklich, oder? Dann noch
die Logik lieber selbst programmieren anstatt dieses rumgeklicken hier. Aber ich glaube,
ihr versteht, was ich meine. Also damit kann man dann auch sich Automatisierung zusammen
klicken. Ja, wunderbar. So sieht es aus. So könnte man das machen. Jetzt haben wir halt
immer noch unseren Knopf für unseren Staubsauger. Wir wissen, dass die Bahn aktuell keine Verspätung
hat nach Dresden. Muss es ja als Noob erst mal hinkriegen. Guck mal, ich habe es auch
nicht richtig hingekriegt. Das ist auch unglaublich kompliziert. Ich meine. Ich meine, guck mal
hier, die Installationanleitung ist schon mal wieder komplett kaputt. Ja. Ach nee, ok,
passt. Steht da sogar drinne, wie es funktioniert. Warum sollte, warum muss man eigentlich Unsafe
per Mode machen? Was macht das denn? Ok, wir installieren mal die Note-Modules und machen
wir das da. Mal gucken, was dann passiert. Also mit dem Befehl kann man es anscheinend
relativ einfach installieren. Ok. Ah, jetzt kann man es direkt starten. Aha. Ja. Ah,
ich habe die Home Assistant Sachen nicht mehr installiert. Ok, das funktioniert noch. Er
denkt irgendwie, dass ich auf einem Raspberry laufe. Warum auch immer. Ja, das Installieren
ist also relativ einfach. Das ist typisches JavaScript, geschwuppelt, erst mal 30 Milliarden
Abhängigkeiten installieren. Ah, das ist drinne. Jetzt kann man erstmal Call Service machen.
So viel einfacher ist es wirklich. Also ich bevorzuge das in Preisen selbst zu programmieren.
So, ja, wir haben es hingekriegt. Kann man euphie mit dem Raspberry steuern. Wunderbar.
Jetzt geht erstmal was futtern. Was für ein System nutzt ihr? Ja, Anstehnungs, das ist
ein Manjaro. Blow it up. Was meinste denn genau? Also es lohnt sich immer dann, Heimautomatisierungsdinger
zu machen, wenn es Sachen gibt, die auf dem... Oh fuck. Mein Hetsad-Verteilungskasten-Ding
ist runtergefallen. Im Prinzip mein übergroßer Mute-Button ist runtergefallen. Wenn es dir
Sachen gibt, die dir auf den Keks gehen. Ja, du sagst, du kriegst morgen nicht mit.
Morgen ist nicht mit, dass die Bahnverspätung hat. Oder wieviel. Da machst du halt für
dich ein Licht in Flur, das dir anzeigt in Orange oder Rot, ob die Bahnverspätung hat.
Es muss halt für dich passen. Deswegen finde ich es auch bescheuert, wenn man diese fertigen
Heimautomatisierungs-Hubs verwendet, die eigentlich nix können im Endeffekt von dem, was man
wirklich braucht. So und jetzt noch was schönes an LXC. Ich habe hier eine Container installiert,
wo wir unsere Heimautomatisierungsgeschichten getestet haben. Dann kann ich jetzt einfach
sagen LXC stopp. Und dann kann ich einfach sagen Delete. Und zack, ist das ganze wieder
rückstandsfrei entfernt. Das braucht eine halbe Minute, bis der Speicherplatz wieder
freigegeben wird oder so. Und dann ist es wieder weg. Deswegen sind Container wirklich
praktische Geschichten. Oh, ich habe nur Donation gekriegt. Die lese ich jetzt auch vor. Und
dann gehe ich schon was futtern. Von Eif. Eif, 3,34 €. Dankeschön. Keine Message. Da
ist das ja. Übrigens schön, dass ihr alle heute dabei seid. Auch nice, dass Eif dabei
ist. Und danke für die ganzen Follows, die es heute gegeben hat. Ich gehe jetzt was futtern.
Und wir sehen uns nächstes Mal. Noch eins sagen, was brauchst du denn alles, um an Zeugs
anzufangen. Damit anzufangen, brauchst du eigentlich nicht wirklich viel. Du musst
dich informieren, was du für eine Funk-Technik nehmen willst. Ich habe Sea-Wave. Du nimmst
dann einen Raspberry oder eine VM von irgendeiner Kiste und fängst an. Brauchst du eigentlich
nix? Großartig. So, aber ich bin jetzt weg. Wir sehen uns nächstes Mal. Macht's gut.
Bis dann. Tschüss.